- Here's a little story
sure to make you smile.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
After a wedding, couples
usually like to look back
at the video of their big day.
Sadly for 14 years,
Drew and Kayla from Oregon couldn't.
That's because when they went
to put their tape on DVD,
they were told it was blank,
which is so sad, and funny.
Years later, Drew got a call
from a friend who it turns out,
had found the wedding
footage at the church.
Instead of just telling his wife,
Drew decided to unveil it
for her in like a big way.
So on their anniversary, he
rented out the local theater.
Kayla thought he was gonna
show her their favorite movie.
And then this happened.
I love that she hadn't seen it.
He surprised her with
rolling their wedding day
on the silver screen.
And we have the couple
on the line right now.
(audience clapping)
Who're watching our partner
station KMTR in Eugene.
So hey Kayla, hey Drew.
(audience cheers)
- Hi Kelly.
- I mean, first of all
Drew this is so romantic.
That's so sweet.
She did well by picking you.
And it must've been heartbreaking though,
to find out that you had
lost your wedding footage.
Like how heartbreaking
was that in the moment?
- I mean,
I knew we still had our pictures
and we'd be able to look back on those,
but there's something
about having the video,
which just gives you that extra layer
of seeing people in action
and hearing the noises and remembering it.
And when I got that call,
that my friend had found them,
I was just overjoyed.
He didn't even know that we
didn't have them at the time,
but I knew I had to plan
some kind of big surprise
cause she was just gonna be ecstatic.
- Oh, that's so cool.
How emotional was that
moment in the theater Kayla?
- Oh my gosh. I was so overwhelmed.
I could not believe that we were watching
our wedding videos.
Like I thought,
how about knew was our
wedding videos and thought,
how on earth does he have these?
Like how are we watching these right now?
But it is just so special
to like see all the people.
Like the guy who married us is super funny
and I remember laughing
and having a good time,
but couldn't quite
remember what he had said.
So its so fun to just remember
everything that really happened that day.
- And now I've told
her it's for next year.
It's her turn to try and top this.
I am done for next year.
- There's no way.
He's so good at surprises.
I can't top this.
- Oh my God. Well, that's so cool.
And also you spend so
much money on that day.
It's good to have it on film.
It's like weddings are expensive.
- For sure.
- Thank you so much Drew and Kayla.
I'm liking your posts right now.
- [Kayla] Thank you so much.
- [Drew] Thank you.
- That's not all y'all our
season long partner Pilot Pen
the go-to pen at the
Kelly Clarkson show thinks
that your story is as sweet as we do.
So in recognition,
there'll be using their
frixion erasable pen
to write you a check for a $1000.
How's that sound?
- [Drew] Thank you so much.
- And also happy anniversary.
That's amazing.
14 years it's amazing
you guys keep it going.